en las últimas horas se han oído
muchísimas declaraciones de cómo está
guerra en siria no deben continuar y hay
que buscar una manera un diálogo
político para salir de este conflicto de
hecho desde varios factores se ha dicho
que no debe continuar otros diez años
más pero estas son palabras que vuelven
a caer en el viento para muchos de los
sitios que hemos hablado con ellos en el
día de hoy durante estos diez años han
habido muchísimas declaraciones
muchísimas posiciones de la comunidad
internacional rechazando tanto la
violencia en un momento del gobierno de
bachar al-assad como los grupos rebeldes
especialmente extremistas como el estado
islámico pero en realidad su vida no ha
cambiado en nada y la situación sigue
estando igual a pesar de que el
conflicto ha disminuido hay menos
violencia sin embargo la situación de la
vida de los sirios sigue siendo bastante
mala especialmente por esta crisis
económica por la que atraviesa el país
sin duda las sanciones económicas
también han afectado a la población
especialmente a los más vulnerables ya
aquellos afectados por la guerra así que
todas estas
ahora siguen siendo palabras al viento
para muchos que no ven una salida a este
conflicto después de 10 años